I know it's just for fun I'm investing I
know I could lose this is Vegas and
Bitcoin fits that category for me
bitcoin is like a zodiac next to the US
dollars Titanic there's a city out here
where the whole city is cryptocurrency
friendly and this is a example of what's
gonna happen to the rest of the world
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world now I started the
cryptocurrency series because I've been
getting a lot of requests and people
trying to understand crypto trying to
understand that they should be putting
their money there starting business
around that what are people saying about
it so that's the point of this series so
today we're going to learn what Tony
Robbins Daymond John Nipsey Hussle
and others think about Bitcoin and
crypto currencies enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one think of Bitcoin like going
to Vegas with pony Robbins
what do you think of Bitcoin I think
it's very iffy I mean you can make it's
like anything right now it's it's really
a gamble nobody knows you saw what's
happened in China and the impact that's
happening right now on Bitcoin from that
so I don't have a clue I look at that as
it's like going to Vegas things that
aren't really predictable they could
make you a lot of money I'd say this is
the money I take certain of my money and
I go this is I know it's just for fun
I'm investing I know I could lose this
is Vegas and Bitcoin fits that category
for me
rule number two understand what bitcoin
is with Andreas Antonopoulos so bitcoin
is internet money it's a system of money
that exists on the internet was created
on the Internet and it allows you to
send and receive value so the same way
you can send and receive an email
anywhere in the world instantaneously
without intermediaries and that's kind
of what you see at first glance behind
that it's a whole platform it is as the
title of the book says the Internet of
money it is it is a set of protocols
that allow you to basically exchange
value with other people but you can do a
lot more with it than just that most
people will use it as a currency it's
basically money that you can transmit
from your smartphone to somebody else's
smartphone directly just
cash but electronic and the thing about
it that's unique is that it's not owned
by any corporation any bank or any
government just like the web isn't owned
by anyone or email isn't owned by anyone
and there's lots of companies that can
send a receive email there's lots of
companies that can set up websites
there's a lot of companies that can set
up applications they use Bitcoin here's
the truth over the seven years that it's
existed the volatility as a percentage
has been going down every single year so
as the economy gets bigger the bigger it
is the more stable it is it doesn't get
buffeted around right it's just like a
very large boat doesn't get pushed
around by the waves bitcoin is like a
zodiac next to the US Dollars Titanic
and the little zodiac is bouncing up and
down on the waves a lot right mm-hmm and
it might be uncomfortable at times of
course if you're heading to an iceberg
you want to be in the thing that can
actually turn on a dime but I don't know
if it's a fair analogy but it's a good
way it's it's volatile and and that's
part of it's part of the fact that a 10
to 12 billion dollar economy stretched
across the entire globe is a small
economy as a currency rule number three
be careful with Daymond John what are
your thoughts on Bitcoin I don't know my
boy Ted over here is gonna look at me
about Bitcoin listen so first of all
digital currency it's here Yeah right no
matter what I think Bitcoin the way I I
surround myself with a whole bunch of
Millennials who know way more than I do
right that's part of my rising cry right
the way they break it down to me is you
know bitcoin is the Yahoo of the
infinite right I think digital
currencies gonna be it's gonna fluctuate
it's gonna go up and down right it's
kind of like the dot-com era right the
kind of Tom era came and went but still
a lot of companies ended up you know
becoming prosperous and things like that
nature I think like any currency it's
gonna be here you just got to be careful
with it because as fast as it can go up
it can go down yeah but you know do like
we do on the stock market listen if
you're you're enjoying some success off
of it
take some of the profits off the table
because now you'll be playing with the
houses money if you have some Bitcoin
right
do that and then you're never gonna lose
rule number four the last one before my
bonus clip is follow the coin with
Nipsey Hussle what is this thing you
know I understand cryptocurrency I
understand unregulated form of currency
I understand peer-to-peer transactions
online but what is follow coin so
basically what it is is there's a
there's a there's a huge amount of value
in this cryptocurrency space with
trading and exchanging different forms
of currency different tons of
acquisition different times of selling
it's very similar to the stock market so
there's people over the last five six
years that became very successful
trading currencies via different
platforms and so what it is there will
be a big trade that takes place and
you'll hear about it next week and
that's how to marry but the opportunity
came in past very similar to stocks so
what happened with follow corn follow
corn gives you the opportunity it blends
the social networking element with the
purely financial element of being
involved in being aware of great
opportunities with socializing people
that know about the great opportunities
so what it is is a mix and it's a it's a
platform where you can follow successful
traders you you already know the top ten
traders in cryptocurrency
and if you don't they'll be listed for
the top 50 or the top 100 however your
dynamic you want to be there's less than
1% penetration and that's a fact because
I can't spend Bitcoin here I got a still
spinning US dollars or MasterCard credit
or you know established credit any one
of these stores there's no penetration
in the real world but there's a
$27 to $800,000 increasing investment in
this space but there's a 1 percent
penetration in the real world so what
happens when it gets five percent we're
a world where more people can spend that
cryptocurrency at the store at the
restaurant on the airplane which is why
we came to Amsterdam because there's a
city out here where the whole city is
cryptocurrency friendly and this is a
example of what's gonna happen to the
rest of the world
and we think that if you get in now when
the value spreads and the accessibility
spreads you'll be sitting on the right
chair and what you do is you're
allocated starting around your
investment budget you'll say I got
100,000 total I got 10,000 total I got
5,000 total and you say I want to
allocate a thousand toward this
influence so the next moves he makes a
thousand dollars of your investment fund
will go with mary his moves in real time
you could be sleek you could be on a
plane you could be wherever he make a
move yo portfolio that you've allocated
towards him will move we move but follow
coin the distinguishing characteristic
is that you're gonna follow the
investors in real time that are
successful in this space already and
it's gonna be based on the amount that
you allocate to each investment that's
the unique feature that's not available
anywhere else or any other platform and
it's proprietary and this is the unique
contribution of follow point offers so
when you ask yourself what do I get why
do I be involved in follow coin you
gotta ask yourself are you interested in
opportunities and financial
opportunities are you willing to invest
in finance or opportunities if you're
not wanting them type of people this
really don't apply to you or appeal to
you if you are this is something you
can't miss this is something you had to
be a part of
now I've got a very special bonus clip
with Roger Vere who was one of the
earliest investors into Bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies but before that I
want to know question today are you
investing into cryptocurrencies what are
your general thoughts have you learned
anything from this video that helps you
or not leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much loved I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
thanks to the invention of Bitcoin for
the very first time in the entire
history of the world
any human being can now send and receive
any amount of money with any other human
being anywhere on the planet
instantly basically for free you don't
have to get permission from a bank you
don't have to get permission from a
corporation you don't have to get
permission from a government not only do
you not have to get their permission
it's impossible for any of those
entities to stop it so you can now send
money from from here in LA - to Moscow
instantly just like that for less than a
penny and there's nothing that the
Russian government can do there's
nothing that the Chinese government can
do there's nothing that the American
government can do so if you think that
it's a good thing that people have
control of their own money and they're
not susceptible to things like we had
happened in Cyprus a few years back
where the government just came in and
said okay we're gonna take I think it
was a third of it everybody's money in
their bank accounts if you think things
like that are bad you should love
Bitcoin and even if you haven't used
Bitcoin yet it might sound complicated
and difficult but think of it like email
if I sat here trying to explain to you
how email worked it would sound really
hard and confusing and how could anybody
figure out how to do this sort of thing
but once you've used email it's not hard
it's easy you just type in the person's
email address and you send them a
message
bitcoins the same way you just paste
copy and paste their Bitcoin address and
you send them some money yeah and so the
best advice I can give to anybody that's
new to Bitcoin don't be afraid of it go
on the internet and get a Bitcoin wallet
and give it a try it's really really
easy to use once you've actually used it
see once wolves long media the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]